president Donald Trump's border barrier
is under construction in southern
Arizona
work crews with heavy equipment are
carving a path through the desert the
wall will go along the southern edge of
the organ pipe cactus National Monument
an area of exceptional beauty the US
National Park Service says the 1340
square kilometer monument preserves one
of the Earth's major ecosystems in
nearly unspoiled condition the United
Nations designated organ pipe National
Monument as an international biosphere
reserve environmentalists say wall
construction threatens this pristine
environment we've got endangered kita
dakedo pupfish also known as the Sonoita
pupfish right here in this stream you
can see them are they an endangered
species they are
I wanna for endangered species here
workers will pump water from underground
to mix concrete for the barriers base
possibly drying out this desert oasis
which is just a few hundred meters from
the border the barrier will block the
normal migration routes of rare animal
species like puma and antelope the human
experience will also change a 50
kilometer nine meter tall wall equipped
with floodlights that are on all night
long that's what's being proposed here
and it's it's insane our night skies are
going to be destroyed we're not gonna be
able to see the stars anymore from the
campground and it's gonna be an eyesore
this is a place that's designated
wilderness it's supposed to look
pristine and now it's gonna look like 50
kilometer prison wall in order to build
the wall President Trump declared a
state of national emergency here on the
border now that together with other
legal loopholes has allowed the
government to completely disregard
numerous laws designed to protect
environmentally sensitive areas like
this environmentalists have taken the
administration to court in an effort to
slow or halt construction but for now
the Walmart
is relentlessly forward Rob Reynolds al
Jazeera near Sonoita Mexico